hasta donde alcanza la vista colas de
coches con gente ansiosa por hacerse una
prueba de coronavirus una escena común
en todo eeuu ya que la nación continúa
luchando contra la pandemia
la batalla por contener los nuevos casos
se está enfrentando a otro obstáculo ya
que el país alcanzó un hito alarmante al
jueves registrando más de 120.000 nuevos
contagios esto rompe el récord
establecido justo el día anterior las
autoridades temen que a medida que el
número de infecciones aumente la
economía continúe sufriendo el peso de
la propagación hay partes de la economía
en las que va a ser difícil hasta que
haya una vacuna mira lo que está pasando
aquí los otro pico de casos a medida que
llega el frío y además la gente está más
en los interiores así que creo que
tenemos que ser un inglés acerca de cómo
vamos con esta enfermedad no ha
desaparecido el mayor aumento de nuevos
contagios se vio registrado en el centro
oeste del país especialmente con el
estado de illinois registrando cerca de
10.000 nuevos casos mientras que estados
como connecticut iowa y main dieron
saltos de más del 45% en nuevas
infecciones
de hospitalizaciones también sigue
aumentando 52 mil 500 personas fueron
ingresadas a los hospitales por el virus
el jueves mientras tanto las autoridades
de dakota del norte reportaron sólo 8
camas de cuidados intensivos gratuitas
en todo el estado a pesar del fuerte
aumento no se ha tomado ninguna medida a
nivel federal para frenar la propagación
del virus y las máscaras no son
obligatorias en 17 de los 50 estados de
eeuu sin embargo algunos estados han
anunciado nuevas restricciones como
toques de queda y límites al número de
personas permitidas en reuniones
privadas